Democrats lose their mind about Brett
Cavanaugh's nomination Bob Woodward's
book launches and Paul Krugman says
Republicans are here to steal your
health care oh happy day i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today this very tumblr will be filled
endlessly with the tears of all of the
people at the Senate Judiciary Committee
hearing it is fully insane over there
where all the women have been reduced to
the status of menial slaves under
president pence and justice Kavanagh has
forced them all into the back alleys for
their abortions we'll talk about all of
those things but first let's talk about
what you're going to do during this
incipient disaster as Brett Kavanaugh
about to join the Supreme Court and
reduce us all to penury to living in our
homes having to eat from food storage
well what are you gonna do when that
happens the answer is you're gonna need
my Patriot supply because the reality is
that regardless of what the disaster is
whether it's Brett Kavanaugh being
appointed to the Supreme Court or
whether it's net neutrality or whether
it's actually just like an actual
natural disaster where you can't leave
your house or go to the grocery store
you're going to need something in your
house to get you through those times the
answer cannot be to run to the grocery
store in a lot of emergency situations
because the shelves are already empty or
the place is closed this is why you need
my Patriot supply for food storage so
you'll be ready for earthquakes
hurricanes long term power outages and
more here's a great special that makes
it simple each person in your household
should have a two-week emergency food
supply from my Patriot supply the kits
are only 75 bucks right now
they contain ninety two servings of
breakfast lunches and dinners take
action call eight eight eight eight oh
three 14 13 or go to my special website
prepare with been calm the food lasts up
to 25 years in storage meals compact in
a rugged slimline tote as well it's only
75 bucks for all that rest tonight
knowing that you're prepared order those
food kits at 888 803 1413 or prepare
with been calm 888 803 1413 or prepare
with been calm okay so the second day of
the Brett Kavanaugh hearings is upon us
Brett Kavanaugh of course is president
Trump's nominee to replace Justice
Kennedy yesterday I mistakenly said
who's gonna replace Scalia but that of
course was justice Gorsuch he is there
to replace Justice Kennedy and the left
is going nuts over this because oh my
god an establishment Republican but the
most establishment of credentials is
going to sit on the Supreme Court and
there's nothing they can do to stop it
because Harry Reid back in 2013 like an
idiot utilize the nuclear option in
order to get through a bunch of judicial
nominees by President Obama over the
filibuster so now it only requires 51
votes to put somebody on a federal court
the Republicans have those 51 votes they
will be using them for Brett Kavanaugh
he will indeed sit on the nation's
highest court
now hilarious about all of this is the
levels of panic to which the left have
been rising in the in the last couple of
days are fully crazy
I mean fully fully crazy well show you
some of that panic in just a second but
Brett Kavanaugh is sitting there
answering questions like what do you
think about roe v-- wade and he's saying
it's precedent and then he's asked about
Planned Parenthood versus Casey and he
says it's precedent on a precedent this
does not sound like a dude who's going
to overturn roe v wade this was always
my criticism of judge Brett Kavanaugh I
didn't think that he was the most right
leaning person that the Republicans
could have picked the most originalist
person Republicans could have picked I
think he'll be a pretty good judge I
think he'll be a pretty good justice I
don't think that he's going to be Thomas
or Scalia I'm not sure that he's a solid
vote to overrule roe v wade but it
doesn't matter what he says at this
point because the Democrats have
basically already made up their mind and
judicial hearings are useless because we
now have something called the so the the
the Ginsburg rule which is has been in
place for some thirty years basically
you can't expect a judge to answer
questions about how they will decide an
upcoming case or even what they really
think of past precedent instead they
just say it's precedent which is a legal
description of the state of the law Roe
is precedent but precedent is not
binding on the Supreme Court because the
Supreme Court can simply overrule
precedents any time that it wants so all
of this is to say that these judicial
hearings are a complete waste of time
they're utter nonsense that are waived
for the for the Senators to grandstand
and apparently for them to bring in all
of their crazy friends to grandstand as
well the hearings were interrupted in
the first 40 minutes 44 times yesterday
by various Democrats shouting out
interruptions also there are a bunch of
people who decided to shout at Brett
Kavanaugh in the room people like Piper
Perabo who's not been relevant since
what coyote ugly she got arrested
yesterday in the worst performance
ironically since coyote ugly she got
arrested yesterday Linda Sarsour of the
women's March was also arrested in the
room she was dragged out kicking and
screaming and you know she is she's a
delight and every in every possible way
so all of these radicals in the room
getting getting dragged away it's it's
just it's just terrific it's just
terrific here's some video of the
protesters screaming because that was
delightful
we're not any negative patient and what
chairman Leahy did during justice
Kagan's this is another example of
confidential documents or really
interesting seeing them in the first
place so here's the rule I think they
should apply I think the rule they
should apply here is that if you invited
anybody in who disrupts the hearing you
don't get to invite anybody in anymore
if you are one of the Democratic
senators and you allowed Code Pink to
come in you'll add Linda Sarsour to come
in then she got herself arrested because
she's a dolt then you don't get to
invite anybody anymore because that's
not what these hearings are for if you
want a protest there's plenty of space
outside for you to protest your protests
will be useless because this is a
democratic process not a protesting and
shouting process but screaming and
whining are the way that the Democrats
are dealing with the fact that they are
not going to be able to get Merrick
garland on the court to replace a
Republican appointee like Justice
Kennedy here is video of Linda Sarsour
getting arrested yesterday she again is
as delight
catch you later Linda
[Applause]
okay if you can understand what they're
saying then you are a you have better
hearing than I do all I hear is the
shrieking of of some sort of primeval
creature in the middle of an in the
middle of a hearing room these are
humans and I'm not calling her an animal
all I'm saying is that shrieking is
inaudible there is no way for you to
tell what she is saying because she's
shrieking like a the people in the room
you're right everybody on that on that
on that panel Orrin Hatch's going you
know what I've changed my vote because
Linda Sarsour is shrieking at me people
in the middle of the country they're
thinking yes disaster is disaster thy
name be Brett Kavanaugh moderates in the
middle of the country independence in
the middle of the country they are
thinking the apocalypse is upon us so
now we've been told by the Democrats
that women and trans folks will die
because of Brett Kavanaugh everybody was
going to die because of net neutrality
everybody already died because of the
tax cuts I mean how many times can
people die already is it's wild it's
it's it's pretty amazing stuff all of
this should also remind you it should
also remind you that when we get all of
this nonsense from the left and from
some members of the right about civility
and our politics Trump being the
beginning and end of civility in our
politics he's the one who ruins civility
yeah sure yeah right it's all about
Trump this is what bugged me about the
McCain funeral where he had George W
Bush and Barack Obama standing up there
kind of creating this mythologized past
where everybody sort of got along and I
was talking with a friend this morning
about what bothered me about that idea
so much and what bothered me about the
idea is that there are those of us who
actually believe that politics matter
and all these politicians prey on us
because what they do is they say you're
right politics do matter and so you got
Joe Biden on the Left saying we'll put
y'all back in Chains and folks on the
right saying this will be the end of the
country unless we do something that's
apocalyptic rhetoric from people on both
sides of the aisle because they're
saying yes you are right
politics do matter and then as soon as
somebody comes along and says you're
right politics matters we're gonna fight
this like a war you've been using this
apocalyptic rhetoric this is going to be
a political war we're gonna fight this
like a war then they say well hold on we
don't want to do that and so they've
been they've been basically doing this
WWE routine for a very long time where
you have every major politician from
both parties speaking like WWE wrestlers
but then telling people they ought to
take it seriously that it's not fake
that in reality these issues actually
matter and then when the people take
those issues seriously
and then when they elect a guy who is
not a politician who takes the things
seriously like Trump actually
the personal conflict seriously
regardless what you think of the guy
then they say well no no he didn't
understand that this was all part of the
game didn't understand he missed it
didn't understand was all part of the
game there's a movie with Robert De Niro
called the fan a long time ago about
this kind of it's it's about a guy who
is a fan of a baseball team and his
baseball team is about to go to the
World Series I think this is how the
plot works and Robert De Niro is a fan
of the baseball team and he is so
enamored with his team's chances of
making the World Series that he goes and
he kidnaps the opposing star on the
other baseball team and everybody in the
world is like why would you possibly do
that he's like well because I want my
team to win because he took the conflict
too seriously I feel like that's sort of
what we've done with our politics a
little bit which is we now root for the
opposing teams the difference being
their actual consequences to which team
wins or losses and so you got the left
claiming at the end of the world is nigh
and the right claim in the end of the
world is nigh and then the minute that
somebody like Trump comes along and says
okay fine if the end of the world is
nigh let's treat this like the brawl
that it is then all of a sudden people
on both sides of the aisle they go whoa
wait up wait up a second wait up a
second we didn't really mean that stuff
and so cool if you didn't mean it then
why did you say it
I agree the end of the world is not nigh
I agreed that we're not at the end of
the country
I agree we're not on the verge of Civil
War I think there are serious divisions
about the future of the country but I
think that most Americans are not
engaged in those serious divisions I
think that's an intellectual
superstructure that really cares deeply
about those divisions I think most
Americans are just going about their
daily business making basic assumptions
about American life that that reflect
the essential founding values of the
country but I think there is this
intellectual upper class where they have
these battles and they know that it's
Kabuki theater and then in the backroom
they get a drink together but they don't
let anyone else in on the secret that
it's Kabuki theater in reality the
actual Kabuki theater should be them
getting along and they should be bashing
each other again I find all of this
really tiresome so what what politics
really does look like in the country the
way people feel right now is like Linda
Sarsour the way people feel in the
country is like Donald Trump they feel
like that they like the wrestling is
real that's what they feel like because
you know what when it comes to the
consequences the wrestling actually
Israel and the fact that our politicians
didn't take it as real for so long and
preyed upon that impression to create
enthusiasm for their mission while all
the time knowing that they were
just exaggerating the case that's what's
created everybody bought into their
vision everybody bought into the
wrestling is real meme and now the
wrestling is real once everybody
believes the wrestling is real then
they're gonna start brawling and that's
basically where we are right now
down to the point where everyone is now
become delusional the left is fully
delusional about these cabinet hearings
and when I say delusional there were two
stories that started making the rounds
yesterday both of which are completely
completely insane so Story number one is
there is a woman named Xena Bosch Xena
Bosch is a half Mexican
half Jewish White House staffer and she
is married to a US attorney I believe
and Xena Bosch was sitting behind Brett
Cavanaugh during these hearings and the
left began claiming that she was making
a white power symbol behind Brett
Kavanaugh I kid you not this thing
within a couple of hours this video of
Xena Bosch who is legitimately just
putting her hand on her arm they're
saying she's making a covert White Power
symbol for no reason just because that's
her sitting racism or something like
they've still not explained why exactly
even if she wired white supremacist
which she is not she's again a half
Mexican half Jewish person Y example
grandparents survived the Holocaust like
why exactly she would be making a white
power symbol behind Brett Kavanaugh is
beyond me but they claimed that she was
legitimately making a white power symbol
behind Brett Kavanaugh and there were a
thousand tweets about this right the
left began tweeting about this
incessantly major blue checkmark figures
on the left began tweeting about all of
this it's it's just insane the ACLU
tweeted out spread the word its hashtag
not okay
neo-nazis are using the okay hand
gesture in commutes to communicate a
hateful message when using the gesture
the fingers form letters wnp which stand
for white power do not use this hand
gesture it's not okay okay Barack Obama
has used this hand gesture you see what
I'm doing right now this is not a white
power symbol I've been using the hand
gesture for okay for my entire life
as have you as have your parents because
that's not a thing in fact the ADL
recognized this is not a thing the
anti-defamation league okay this is what
they this is what they wrote back in
September 2018 they updated it yesterday
has the simple thumb and forefinger okay
hand gesture become a common white
supremacist hand signal not quite but it
has become a popular gesture used by
people across several segments of the
right and far right including
actual white supremacist who generally
use it to trigger reactions or what they
would describe as trolling the libs
this is thanks to a 20-17 hoax campaign
started by members of the notorious
website 4chan that has since taken on a
life of its own
I'm gonna explain a little bit more
about this in just one second but first
let's talk about your use of stamps so
listen I know I know that you love the
post office but you probably don't want
to go down to the post office spend the
time in the car the whole deal instead
why don't you just do all of your
postage from your desk it's a lot easier
and stamps calm brings all the great
services of the post office directly to
your desk 24/7 when it's convenient for
you you can buy and print official US
postage for any letter any package using
your own computer and printer mail
carrier picks it up just click print
mail you're done couldn't be easier
stamps calmly use it here at the Daily
wire offices it's great it saves us all
sorts of time which for us means money
and right now when you use promo code
Shapiro you get up to 55 bucks a free
postage a digital scale and a four week
trial go to stamps calm before you do
anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in Shapiro that stamps comm again
promo code Shapiro stamps comm promo
code Shapiro stamp Stockholm is a great
way to ensure that you are saving all
the money you need to save and you don't
actually have to go out to the post
office just do it for me to ask stamps
comm use promo code Shapiro for the
special deal
so the ADL continues by saying this is
all thanks to a 27 hoaxes campaign
started by members of the notorious
website 4chan that has since taken on a
life of its own the 4chan site is an
anonymous discussion board with an
outsized cultural impact on the internet
it has been responsible for everything
from the I Can Has Cheezburger cat meme
to the concept of rickrolling there's
little chant there is little that four
channels like as much as a hoax and in
recent months they've served up a number
of faker ease with white supremacist
themes to to largely credulous online
audiences the okay hand gesture
originated is one of these hoaxes in
February 2017 when an anonymous 4chan er
announced to operation Oh KKK telling
other members we must flood Twitter and
other social media websites claiming the
OK hand sign is a symbol of white
supremacy the user even provided a
helpful graphic showing how the letters
white power could be traced within an
okay gesture I believe the way that it
works is you can see it here in the in
the ACLU meme supposedly it's like if
you go like this then this is a w-4 like
white and then I guess the power is like
that thing I
okay the whole thing is trolling the
whole thing is stupidity it's all reddit
making fun of you it's all fortune
making fun of you and the entire left
fell for it they said that Xena Bosch
was responsible for white supremacy
again a half Mexican half the Jews are
so clever that they activated a half
Mexican half Jewish person to unleash a
white power symbol to hit the media and
get Brett Kavanaugh nominated I guess
something like that but there are a
bunch of people on the Left who tweeted
this stuff out like a lot of them if
this became an actual thing on Twitter
Keith - Keith - Maya or dumbass is the
case maybe who is she what's up with the
white power sign at MSNBC it's got to
work in tweeted out it's the biggest
mistake I've ever made
real Donald Trump said after having to
condemn a fellow white supremacist after
charlottesville just in case you were
wondering what side trump's on its on
the side of the nazis the same side
Republicans in Congress are on and then
somebody replied so are some of the
hearings notice her hand
WTF okay you guys are idiot you guys are
idiots this is like the left's pizza
gate there they're idiots on all sides
they're conspiracy theorists on all
sides this is just the latest conspiracy
theory but it is not the only conspiracy
theory so there's another conspiracy
theory going around yesterday
there's promoted by a guy named Fred
Guttenberg Fred Gutenberg's daughter was
killed tragically in the parkland
shooting in an act of tremendous evil
obviously and Gutenberg is a motivated
leftist he's been a motivated leftist
for a long time and Guttenberg basically
went to this hearing with the sole
intention of trying to get Brett
Kavanaugh not nominated he tweeted in
advance that he wants to see Brett
Kavanaugh not nominated and he was going
to the hearing to try and stop that so
he tweeted out here's what he tweeted he
tweeted just walked up to judge Kavanagh
as morning session ended put out my hand
to introduce myself as Jaime Gutenberg's
dad he pulled his hand back turned his
back to me and walked away I guess he
did not want to deal with the reality of
gun violence
okay this flew around the internet I
mean flew around the internet chris
cuomo claimed that this was a true story
chris cuomo did a whole story about how
Kavanagh had ignored fred Guttenberg all
this was just Cavanaugh being vial to
the parents of a parkland survivor yeah
CNN is not fake news that they're just
annapolis an apple and a bananas and
banana and CNN is news not fake news
news here's Chris Cuomo again really
gaining on his brother in the dumb Cuomo
brothers race he last week Andrew had
pulled
had like Secretariat but now here it
comes like Man O'War up from behind
pretty amazing stuff anyway here's Chris
Cuomo giving credence to this story
which turns out to be a fool why the
judge should be asked why well justice
is supposed to be blind but that means
I'm biased not ignoring what is right in
front of your face why did you do that I
don't mean to indict him he may have a
good reason it may have no reason may
say I don't even know what you're
talking about I didn't even know it was
going on I just want to get out of there
maybe but we need to hear it why because
I hope that in Cavanaugh's mind
Gutenberg didn't represent a set of
beliefs that he finds so threatening but
he couldn't even make contact that's why
the judge oh my oh my god so judge
Cavanaugh now has to explain why a Rando
I mean it lets me Atlas beard opens Fred
Gutenberg is not a famous person if you
met Fred Gutenberg on the street you
would have no idea who he was you were
more likely to know who Steve Guttenberg
is than who Fred Guttenberg is you have
no clue who Fred Guttenberg is you've
probably never seen his face this is not
a famous human being it's not like Brad
Pitt walked up to him and extended his
hand okay it's a guy who would have to
explain who he was now here is the
actual video of what happened from
inside the room you will see that this
is not what happens okay judge Kavanagh
is excused what you're gonna see here is
judge Cavanaugh gets up Gutenberg
approaches him from behind extends his
hand Kavanagh turns to look at him and
see what's going on and then security
grabs him okay security is already on
him and Cavanaugh walks away okay that's
what happens there it's not that he
stands there and then refuses to shake
his hand you can see here comes security
from behind to grab Cavanaugh now I have
been in positions many positions in
crowded areas where people are assuring
me out of a room and people want to
shake my hand this happens to me at
university campuses all the time and if
somebody extends their hand and security
walks up to them I'm not gonna walk over
there I assume that security is doing
that for a reason do you really think
that Brett Kavanaugh is really like you
know what I can't shake this guy's hand
because I know who he is and I just
stain him I disdain him do you really
think that that's credible in any way
again you can see the video from behind
as security runs up to grab Guttenberg
because he's running up at a break to
try and shake Cavanaugh sand again this
was all planted this is all done on
purpose Guttenberg said in advance that
he was attempting to sink Cavanaugh's
nomination and then suddenly he got
exactly what he wants when Cavanaugh
supposedly stiffs him what absolute
horse crap it's just horse crap in the
video
shows that it's horse crap Cavanaugh had
to change his story I mean not Cavanaugh
Guttenberg had to change his story
originally he claimed that Cavanaugh
clearly hurt him and then cabin I
decided to walk away then he claimed
that maybe Cavanaugh didn't hear him it
didn't matter he was featured all over
the news last night all of this is sheer
nonsense it's sure nonsense so Ben Sasse
apparently now has to explain to
Democrats how these judicial hearings
are supposed to work and here is Ben
Sasse senator from Nebraska giving a bit
of an education to folks on how these
hearings are supposed to work and how
dumb these hearings have become I want
to make just four brief points number
one in our system the legislative branch
is supposed to be the center of our
politics number two it's not third
consequence is that this transfer of
power means the people yearn for a place
where politics can actually be done and
when we don't do a lot of big actual
political debating here we transfer it
to the Supreme Court and forth and
finally we badly need to restore the
proper duties and the balance of power
from our constitutional system okay and
he's right about all these things but
we're not gonna do any of that stuff
instead what we're gonna do is shout at
each other and pretend that Fred
Guttenberg got stiffed by Brett
Kavanaugh and scream until were arrested
and all the rest of this nonsense
because the apocalyptic rhetoric is the
is the name of the game it's what we are
all supposed to focus in on and then as
soon as anyone takes the apocalyptic
rhetoric seriously and and says you know
what I don't like you anymore because
we're not gonna be friends we're not
gonna pretend to be friends because hey
the country is at stake then it's well
don't you get the game don't you get how
the game works you can't have it both
ways either you can use the apocalyptic
rhetoric and take this thing seriously
or you could actually use true rhetoric
and then maybe we could be a little bit
civil to one another and not everything
is the apocalypse and I'm sorry judge
Brett Kavanaugh joining the Supreme
Court is far from the apocalypse it is
really really far from the apocalypse in
just a second I'm gonna give you the
latest on Bob Woodward who has a new
book coming out and this of course has
the left and it's his he because at any
time there's a gossip book about the
president they're up for it but first
let's talk about a sexy topic your air
filters I know you're thinking right now
why do I want to think about my air
filters the answer is because you
haven't thought about it for a while and
you're probably breathing gunk the
reality is you need to go check out your
air filters right now open up that vent
what you're gonna see is a dirty air
filter because you haven't replaced it
forever which is why you need to head
over to my friends over at filter buy
this is especially important with 95% of
the glow
population breathing unsafe air so do
the smart thing go to filter by comm
America's leading provider of HVAC
filters for homes and small businesses
choose from over 600 sizes including
custom options that chip free within 24
hours plus they support working
Americans manufacturing all their
filters right here in the United States
save five percent when you subscribe for
auto replacement so you'll never forget
to change those filters ever again you
will always ensure that you're breathing
clean air filter by will save you time
and money and you're gonna breathe
better and apparently become more
intelligent in the process I mean that's
that's apparently what's happened all
the folks at the office since we
replaced the filters with filter by so
stop procrastinating right now that's
filter Bui com filter by comm tell them
I sent you again its filter by comm
filter bu ID I kind of get on that auto
schedules to save five percent and then
you never have to think about your
filters ever again
it's the meanwhile while all of this is
going on the media are in a tizzy about
President Trump as always because we now
suffer from wilds at Trump derangement
syndrome in the media Bob Woodward has a
new book and his new book basically says
that Trump is a senile old crazy person
who doesn't know what he's doing which
is not much of a claim since I think the
entire two left thinks that and I think
large swaths of the right have basically
priced in all of the typical Trump
craziness into whatever it is that
President Trump does nonetheless we're
going to hear all these stories about
the chaos that is president Trump that I
think the funniest part of this is the
Bob Woodward it's a Trump is denying any
of this is true members of his
administration are denying any of this
is true General James mad dog mattis
says that Woodward is reporting on him
is fiction and quote a product of
someone's rich imagination because
Woodward wrote the Matis once described
Trump as having the understanding of a
fifth or sixth grader when it comes to
the Korean Peninsula mattis responded by
saying the contemptuous words about the
president attributed to me in Woodward's
book were never uttered by me or in my
presence while I generally enjoy reading
fiction this is uniquely Washington
brand of literature and his anonymous
sources do not lend credibility this is
not supremely shocking stuff Woodward is
gonna claim people said stuff people in
the administration didn't claim they
didn't state say stuff this is the
problem with anonymous sourcing it's
he-said she-said
according to the book mattis said after
a meeting at which from questioned the
US government spending money on the
Korean Peninsula mattis supposedly said
that he was exasperated and alarmed and
he told close associates the president
acted like and had the understanding of
a fifth or sixth grader apparently the
defense Chiefs
said in his statement responsible
policymaking in the real world is
inherently messin messy though it is
also essential that we challenge every
assumption to find the best option he
says in serving this administration the
idea would show contempt for the elected
commander-in-chief President Trump or
tolerate disrespect to the office of the
president from within our Defense
Department is a product of someone's
rich imagination so Madison already
throwing shade at Bob Woodward's book
but that's not stopping the press we're
having a field day with all of this
presidents from conversation with Bob
Woodward Woodward apparently called up
Trump and wanted to know why Trump
wouldn't be interviewed for the book and
from basically shied it off he basically
says you know you didn't go through the
proper channels here's Trump trying to
pretend that Canton heard about
Woodward's book and then saying that he
did hear about Woodward's book we didn't
want to talk to him the reality is Trump
doesn't have to talk to to Bob Woodward
there's nothing there that suggests that
that Trump has to for any reason talk to
Bob Woodward it's just another book that
smacks the president know shot here
people and like Kellyanne and Raj in
Republican senators I mean nor the
senators no they never called me about
senator Graham said he had talked to you
about talking to me now is that not true
senator Graham actually mentioned it
quickly on one meeting and that is true
well that no but that is true so
basically there's Trump basically saying
I was mentioned to a lot of people that
I should talk to you I've decided not to
or if somebody else's fault would
release the tapes basically to show that
his research is true and then he has
tapes from a lot of these people
regardless I'm not saying anything in
the book that is anything different from
what people already believe about
President Trump so for example the
Washington Post reports a central theme
of the book is the selfie machination is
used by those in Trump's inner sanctum
to try to control his impulses and
prevent disasters both for the president
personally and for the nation who's
elected to lead woodward describes an
administrative coup d'etat and a nervous
breakdown of the executive branch with
senior aides conspiring to pluck
official papers from the president's
desk so you couldn't see or sign them
again and again woodward recounts at
length how trumps national security team
was shaken by his lack of curiosity and
knowledge about world affairs and his
contempt for the mainstream perspectives
of military and intelligence leaders in
one particular situation
supposedly Gary cone
actually took a document off of Trump's
desk to prevent him from fighting which
is actually somewhat hilarious and so
there's all these stories about how how
his advisers are basically attempting to
rein President Trump in is all this
believable of course this stuff's
believable I'm not gonna sit here and
pretend it's not believable that his
advisors are all trying to rein him in
and prevents him from doing dumb things
that's not a shock in in any real way
and Woodward reports on some of these
overdramatic moments of escalation when
Steve Bannon for example started
screaming at Ivanka Trump calling her a
GD staffer and saying you walk around
this place act like you're in charge or
not you're on staff and I found could
Trump replying I'm not a staffer I'll
never be a staffer and the first
daughter and Reince Priebus saying when
you put a snake in a rat in a falcon in
a rabbit and a shark and a seal in a zoo
without walls things start getting nasty
and bloody okay I mean all this stuff
like frankly who cares I I got to be
honest with you
who cares wait did you not know this is
going on did you not really believe this
is going on do you really believe that
this place functions like a well-oiled
machine of course it doesn't function
like a well-oiled machine it functions
like the set of The Apprentice except
without all of the good editorial cuts
it functions like what left got left on
the cutting room at the apprentice
because that's how Trump runs things
hey and so far the economy is fine and
we're on the middle of any foreign
crisis and things are basically okay I
will say the feeling of chaos from the
Trump administration is really what's
hurting president Trump's approval
ratings now the latest the latest
revelations from Woodward's book come
courtesy of a cos so this is this is
what Woodward writes the operations of
the Oval Office and White House were
less the art of the deal and more often
the unraveling of the deal the
unraveling was often right before your
eyes at Trump rally on continuous loop
there was no way not to look so here is
some of the stuff that that would
reports Trump to James clapper then
Director of National Intelligence who
briefed him at Trump Tower during the
transition on the intelligence
community's findings that Putin had
interfere in the election quote I don't
believe in human sources these are
people who have sold their souls and
sold out their country
I don't trust human intelligence and
these spies so he didn't believe but we
know that he tweeted that stuff out
already
I think okay apparently secretary mattis
said secretaries of the defense don't
always get to choose the president they
work for okay why would that be shocking
Trump said to Tom Bossert the
president's advisor for homeland
security cyber security and
counterterrorism who asked Trump if he
had
Minute quote I want to watch the Masters
your cyber are gonna get me in a war
with all your cyber bleep alright I mean
like again baked into the cake man
everybody knew all this stuff
Trump was given a Reader's Digest
version of the Hezbollah briefing and we
knew this has been reported for years
that Trump basically takes his security
briefings in bite-sized chunks and
apparently Trump was editing an upcoming
speech with Rob Porter scribbling his
thoughts and neat clean penmanship the
president wrote trade is bad and I do I
do love this apparently the books last
paragraph is in the man and his
presidency Trump Boyer John's out had
seen the tragic flaw on the political
back-and-forth the evasions denials the
tweeting the obscure and crying fake
news the indignation Trump had one
overriding problem that that Dowd knew
but could not bring himself to say to
the president you're an effing liar yeah
I don't know what's the media is going
crazy over all this stuff I don't know
why I will be frank with you I do not
understand why there is nothing there
that is new if you didn't know all this
stuff about President Trump before it's
because you haven't been watching or
because you're willfully ignorant
President Trump does not know a lot
about politics he just doesn't okay
that's that's okay yeah being ignorant
about things does that mean you're a bad
president it really doesn't like the
great lie about being the president of
the United States did you have to be an
expert on things you really do not have
to be an expert on things Jimmy Carter
was a very smart man and a really truly
awful President of the United States
we've had a lot of presidents who are
very smart and garbage presidents
Woodrow Wilson was the Dean of Princeton
University and one of the worst
presidents in American history and you
don't have to be great at organization
either to be a decent president you know
many administration's fed chaos in their
first couple of years Bill Clinton had
chaos in his first couple of years none
of this is a real shock but the media
are going to seize on it and claim that
this means that Trump is senile and he
shouldn't be President none of it has
any relevance none of it is a big deal
there's only one way in which any of
this is a big deal and that's the
feeling of constant chaos emanating from
the White House and it leads me to
believe that Trump should basically fire
half of the people who are in the
executive branch right now just to
prevent them from leaking so that there
is some sort of semblance of normalcy at
least emanating from from the halls of
the White House so we'll talk a little
bit more about that plus a bad poll for
Republicans a few bad polls for
congressional Republican
bad poll for Republicans about young
Americans but first let's talk about
your second Amendment rights what if I
told you that when you watch your
mailbox today you're gonna find fifteen
hundred bucks
you've been needing to finally buy the
gun of your dreams to protect your
family and your freedom you could pick
your favorite 1911 a new ar-15 or a new
hunting rifle well that dream is going
to come true for ten of my listeners
thanks to my good friends over at the US
ECA they provided education training
protection to responsible gun owners
like you and me
simply go to defend your family now calm
right now to instantly lock in your 10
free chances to win go to defend your
family now calm it's easy quick 100
percent free but your opportunity to
pick any gun off the shelf is slipping
away right now it ends soon the 10 lucky
gun lovers will each receive 1500 bucks
to buy any gun they want head over to
defend your family now calm right now
lock in those ten free chances to win
before it's too late don't get left
behind that's defend your family now
calm again defend your family now calm
us CCA does great work educating people
on gun use they are there to provide
legal defense services for you if God
forbid you actually have to fire your
gun at somebody because they're in your
house trying to Robbie or something go
check them out right now defend your
family now calm and when you do you can
lock in your 10 free chances to win
before it's too late again defend your
family now calm all right so what does
any of this matter what does any of this
matter we'll talk about that in just one
second first go over to daily wire calm
and subscribe for $19.99 a month 99
$9.99 a month you get the rest of this
show live there are some Andrew Clavin
still alive the rest of Michael Noel's
shall live in for $99 a year you also
get this and very greatest and beverage
vessels it is feeling even as we speak
even as we speak the leftist years are
automatically filling this thing making
it weightier and wait here you can see
my hand drops because it grows so
weighty with the leftist tears that fill
it my goodness we're going to have to
have clean-up on aisle 7
pretty soon as this thing overflows so
go check that out right now it is
cheaper in the monthly subscription also
when you subscribe you got the the
Sunday special so on you go to youtube
you go to iTunes you can subscribe leave
us review over there we appreciate it we
have a Sunday special this week
featuring Christina Hoff Sommers the
factual feminist
and here's what it will sound like i'm
christina hoff sommers
the factual feminist
and this Sunday I'm going to be on the
bench appear Oh show his Sunday special
so please listen because we've broken
the glass ceiling here he's never had a
woman on the Sunday special this will be
the first so join us so there it is and
christina hoff sommers you can hear that
this Sunday it'll be great
go check it out right now and we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so the polls for the president have
dropped in the last couple of weeks
people trying to figure out exactly why
he's down to about thirty nine point six
percent in the average approval rating
he's been very sticky in his approval
ratings like his high is 42
he's down near his lows right now the
Congressional generic ballot is really
bad right now
we're talking about like an eight to ten
point gap for Republicans on average in
the Real Clear Politics poll average
people trying to figure out why there
are three big polls that have recently
come out that are bad for the president
in which he's in the 30s an approval
rating for the first time in a long time
and the reason is because all of the
good news about the economy all of the
good news about the country have been
obscured by the feeling of total chaos
and this is where the media really do
play a role and where the president
playing into the teeth of the media is
really not useful it's where if the
president went silent and deprived them
of oxygen he'd be much better off so
today for example the president decides
that would be wise to tweet out about
all of the media members who are
targeting him and he tweets out with
regard to supposedly libel on the part
of the media he tweeted out let's see
here it is isn't a shame isn't it a
shame he's replying Bob Woodward that
someone can write an article or book
totally make up stories and part of a
picture of a person that is literally
the exact opposite of the fact and get
away with it without retribution or cost
don't know why Washington politicians
don't change libel laws I mean let's be
honest here it'd be very bad thing for
the President of the United States if
they changed the libel laws Ted Cruz
would sue him for suggesting that his
dad shot JFK's there's that I mean this
is the president who said the National
Enquirer should win a Pulitzer Prize but
with all of that said when the president
is feeding the flames here it is not
good it's not useful it gives a feeling
that that things are in uproar when
really they are not and Trump says
almost everyone agrees that my
administration has done more in less
than two years than any other
administration in the history of our
country I'm tough as hell on paper and
if I weren't nothing would get done
also I questioned everybody and
everything which is why I got elected so
that's fine that's fine and then he said
here's what he should be tweeting right
the Trump economy is booming with the
help of House and Senate GOP a farm bill
with snap work requirements will bolster
farmers and get America back to work
passed the farm bill with snap work
requirements now I'm gonna show
why it is that people here it is finally
the president science sounding off on
Nike as well because that's what we
needed
he said just like the NFL whose rings
have gone way down
Nikes getting absolutely killed with
anger and boycotts I wonder if that any
idea it would be this way as far as the
NFL is concerned I just find it hard to
watch and always will until they stand
for the flag this feeling of WWE
incipient chaos everybody is going nuts
over each other all the time I will show
you why it is that president Trump's
approval ratings have been lowered the
only one of those four Suites that's
actually important is the one where he
is calling for work requirements added
to the farm bill that is the only one of
those four tweets that means anything
we're not changing libel laws the NFL
can do it at once Nike and kids do it at
once they're both corporations they're
both gonna feel the brunt of what
they've done and president Trump
suggesting that how he runs his
administration tweeting crazily with
weird punctuation
that's not how pull either the only one
of those four tweets that matters is the
one reason ELISA jesting a policy fix
when it comes to food stamps here are
the number of retweets on each of those
tweets on the one I'm liable fifteen
thousand retweets thirty five thousand
comments fifty-nine thousand likes I'm
the one about how greatest
administration is forty eight thousand
likes thirteen thousand retweets
seventeen thousand comments on the farm
bill five thousand comments
six thousand retweets twenty seven
thousand likes it's about half of all
the other stuff no one pays attention
when the president talks policy everyone
pays attention when he engages in the
culture war kind of stick where a forty
six thousand likes for the anti Nike
tweet people are tired people are tired
they really are and I think most
Americans are just weary at this point
and the president constantly feeding
into the narrative is driving the
weariness I'm not saying that he can't
fight back I think that it's good that
he fights back when lies are told I
think that's fine
but I do think that it is a mistake that
the President of the United States is
constantly engaging it's it's
extraordinarily exhausting for the
American people who mostly just want to
go about their business I was talking to
a friend of mine Dave Rubin yesterday he
just took off 30 days to be off the grid
he like put his cell phone in a safe he
didn't look at the news for 30 days he
came back looking happier than I've seen
him in quite a while
and the reason is because in those
thirty days it has been 10 years of news
he
whirring for the American public most
Americans don't want to be bothered with
government in fact the conservative
pitch is that when government doesn't
bother to you your life is happy when
one of the ways government bothers you
is when it's in your face all the time
and a 24/7 news cycle where the
president is feeding the flames every
day and the media love it let's not
pretend the media don't love it they
love it they're into it all that's doing
is making people annoyed I think that's
really what's happening here I think the
poll numbers are dropping for Trump and
the Republicans because people are just
annoyed and I think they're also
dropping because Republicans aren't
talking about key issues they're not
talking about the things that are
important they're busy running after the
headline of the day there's a poll from
YouGov showing half of those under 35
say America is special compared to 80
percent of people 55 and over you want
to know why that is because Republicans
don't talk about why America is special
anymore
they just talk about whatever is the
latest outrage of the day chasing the
headlines does not win hearts and minds
speaking to true eternal values that
actually matters those are the things
that win hearts and minds and bring
people over we have an inordinately
large young people audience on the show
we do a huge audience most of our
audience on the show is actually under
the age of 40 that's unusual the reason
is because we talk about we try to talk
about these eternal values the things
that actually matter and when you fill
all the space with chatter all the time
all you're doing is allowing the left to
subsume those greater eternal values
under a narrative of chaos that's where
the president should really really cut
it out now speaking of stupid stories of
the day I got to tell you this story
from the UK Sun and there's an amazing
story transgender woman in tears after
bank account frozen as she sounded like
a man on the phone yeah this is his
story from a national newspaper a
transgender woman was left in tears
after her bank account was frozen
because she sounded like a man over the
phone like a man is in quotation marks
Sophia Rees 47 said she was humiliated
and embarrassed after telephone banking
staff said she failed security checks
because she didn't quote speak like a
lady things went from bad to worse the
next day when she went to pay for items
in Tesco and discovered that Santander
had frozen her account now she is
fighting to ensure that other
transgender people are not treated in
the same way Sofia a customer service
adviser living in Nottingham went into
her local Santander branch to confront
staff after the humiliating telephone
ordeal she said
the embarrassment and humiliation I felt
was unbelievable they said my voice did
not match my profile because it sounded
like a man on the phone and not a woman
the whole situation is inadmissible I
was crying my eyes out and I am not that
type of person at all
I'm a very courteous person I am
outgoing but to feel that way when all I
asked for was my money to be transferred
I feel mistreated Sophia informed
Santander last November should no longer
be named Sergio on the account but
despite changing her registered name and
telling phone banking staff she was a
transgender woman they still treated her
with suspicion well right because um
this is what customer service is trained
to do there's literally an entire
identity theft ad campaign by Citibank
that is on television on national
television in which you see two old
ladies sitting there speaking with the
voice of southern men because the idea
is that southern men have stolen their
credit card if I were a customer service
representative and somebody called in
and said Perry this is Sofia can you
open up the money but really Sofia you
sound like a dude because in fact it
turns out that Sofia is a biological man
so we all have to be crazy now in order
to make room for the feelings of various
other human beings it's just amazing
stuff and the madness of left is not
restricted to that sort of thing the
left has gone so crazy that they're not
just killing basic ideas of rationality
they're also killing the far left
they're killing basic ideas of comedy so
this is my favorite piece of the day
this is from vulture by a person named
Jesse David Fox the title of the piece
is how funny does comedy need to be it
turns out the left is now realizing that
all of their comics are no longer funny
they are going for as we've called it on
the show clap derp right now not a term
that I coined but a term that we have
used on the show clapped her they're not
going for laughter they just want people
to cheer for them
so here is what vulture writes why so
serious to quote a famous clown is a
question being asked about comedy more
and more frequently by its consumers and
by comedians themselves to the point
where some are questioning if it can
even be called comedy Nanette is more a
TED talk than a stand-up special was a
common refrain this summer is drew
Michael even a stand-up special was a
question I was asked about the audience
free HBO tour to take it to scripted TV
I'm frequently reminded of a joke from
difficult people
when did comedies become 30-minute
dramas comedians and comedy writers are
increasingly pushing the bounds of what
it means for something to be a comedy in
the most basic sense rewiring the
relationship between comedies and jokes
so what is comedy without jokes it's
post comedy so it's not that comedians
are unfunny because they've decided to
politically engage and be really crappy
political pundits like I would be a bad
comedian they are very bad political
pundits I know because I'm a
professional but they say that this is
not post comedy I do love this I'm now
going to use this excuse on everything
if I'm bad at cleaning up the house I'm
gonna say to my wife you know what I'm
just post cleaning the house I'm post
cleaning the house you know we've moved
on to a different level it's um kind of
meta you may have a tough time
understanding this but cleaning the
house doesn't actually have to be
cleaning the house
it can really be more the perception
that the house ought to be clean and
then I didn't really do the cleaning but
I think there's meaning in thinking
about but not cleaning the house it's
called post cleaning the house I'm gonna
do this with everything all right I'm
not gonna be entertaining on be
incredibly boring
well hello post entertainment it won't
because does entertainment really need
to be entertaining or is it that is that
just our subjective perception of what
entertainment ought to be entertaining
maybe what entertainment ought to be is
just my general with Andre except three
hours will be eight hours of Wallace
Shawn talking some dude about weird
random art will do that for like eight
hours I'm great it'll be post
entertainment you may know that they you
know that a form of art is dead when
they've declared the art post art comedy
is dead because they have now declared
it post comedy vulture writes sure it
sounds pretentious
it's a pretentious shift especially for
a form that has always seemed allergic
to pretension but it seems like the best
way to describe comedy it's looking more
like the frowning mass than the smiling
one or alternatively these people are
not remotely funny because they can't be
funny anymore
because they've killed the joke the left
has killed every joke because everything
is offensive now so instead they've
decided to opt for a bunch of of of
clapping clap applause generating lines
that rip on president Trump just amazing
stuff okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today there's a good
book called the boys in the boat by
Daniel James Brown it has been made into
a documentary by PBS it's about the
Washington rowing team and and them
essentially rowing for gold at the 1936
Berlin Olympics it's really entertaining
if you like Seabiscuit the book which is
much better than the movie by the way by
Laura Hillenbrand this isn't quite as
good as that book but it is definitely
in
painting read and a moving read it's
it's pretty great like you don't have to
like rowing or know anything about
rolling to enjoy the book I don't know
anything about rowing I enjoyed the book
you can go check it out right now the
boys in the boat nine Americans in their
epic quest for gold it's a nice kind of
reminder that America used to be kind of
an awesome place
America is still an awesome place but
America at least used to be united by
certain basic ideas of hard work and and
motivation and getting ahead and now it
seems like America's motivated mostly by
us kicking each other in the ass which
is which is really irritating okay time
for a bunch of things that I hate so
let's do a lot of hate today so Monica
Lewinsky was appearing at in Israel and
the interviewer asked her if she
expected an apology from former
President Bill Clinton and then she got
up and walked off the stage so here's
here's what that sounded like there
recently an interview and then DC news
president former president was rather
apologized and he said I apologize oh
I'm so sorry I'm not going to be able to
do this
okay so here's what I hate about this
can we stop playing victim for just a
second the only reason Monica Lewinski
is famous is because she once got on her
knees for the President of the United
States that is legitimately the only
reason that she is famous so I feel bad
for Monica Lewinsky I feel like she was
mistreated particularly by the press
that claimed that she was something
terrible and awful when in fact she was
just a young intern who was being put in
a bad position by a man in power but if
we were going to pretend that Monica
Lewinsky gets to act offended by people
asking questions about the only thing
that has ever been politically relevant
about her career I can't go there with
you I can't Monica Lewinsky is not a
victim she's a victim of Bill Clinton
but she's not a victim and she's victim
the press she's not a victim of the lady
asking her about whether Bill Clinton
ought to apologize to her that's a
ridiculous insane thing there's no
reason for that at all and so it's it's
just I find this sort of stuff where we
all get to take offense at everything
it's really dumb okay other things that
I hate as I've been talking about all
show long the left apocalyptic rhetoric
with regard to everything happening in
the country it is more likely to lead to
the actual apocalypse when you think
everything is the apocalypse this leads
people to take up war stances on issues
that really don't merit it Eugene
Robinson is complicit in this today he's
writing over at the Washington Post and
he has a piece called what's at stake in
November democracy democracy itself is
at stake if you really believe that if
you really believe the democracy itself
is at stake that if Democrats don't win
back Congress in 2018 democracy is over
you're out of your damn mind you're out
of your mind if they don't win in 2018
there's very high likelihood that they
will win in 2020
I remember Republicans were saying the
same before 2010 democracy was over we
were all going to die can we quit with
all of the it's the last election
nonsense look if the left gets elected
terrible things will happen in American
politics things I don't like and then
guess what there will be more elections
because America is not on the brink of
collapse as a nation we are on the brink
of a lot of bad things we're on the
brink of hating each other more than
ever we're on the brink of a collapse of
our of our social fabric but that is
going to that is going to long predate
the death of democracy the exaggeration
in which we suggest that democracy is
basically at the end of its rope if
Trump is is you get some Republican
Congress is just nonsense Eugene
Robinson says Trump desperately wants an
attorney general who will shut Mullen in
come in Jeff Sessions cannot do so
because he's recused from the matter
Republican senators once warned from not
to dare fire sessions now seem resigned
to the fact Trump will do just that it
makes sense for Trump to make his move
after the election
if Republicans still control Congress
he'll get away with it if Democrats take
charge he won't if anyone asks you
what's at stake in November just tell
them democracy and justice guess what if
from fires Jeff Sessions and Republicans
don't do anything and then the next
Attorney General fires Robert Muller do
you think Trump's gonna win reelection
in 2020 you think there won't be any
reaction to that
how you think Democrats are gonna do in
2020 if Trump goes forward with that
stuff you think it'll be good I highly
doubt it but we're gonna get this sort
of insane rhetoric anyway from the left
Paul Krugman doing the same thing he
says that again the Republican program
on health care is get sick go bankrupt
and die so if you disagree with him and
his ridiculous plans on health care if
you think that the ACA needs to be
wildly dismembered because it is a bad
bill if you think that there are better
ways to solve for market oriented
solutions in health care then perhaps
what you really ought to do is is what
you really mean according to Paul
Krugman is that you want everybody to
die this sort of apocalyptic rant then
they wonder why you get Trump again
Trump is a symptom the reason why people
say things like why you got Trump is
because people want to see Trump is a
cause this is why this phrase really
crops up like I'm a deep level everybody
on the left doesn't like the phrase why
you got Trump because it implies that
Trump is a symptom rather than a cause
of our Civic collapse Trump is a symptom
he is not the cause Trump is just the
capstone on a couple of decades worth of
really bad politics probably at least
four decades worth going back to the the
excesses of the 1970s and 1960s in terms
of the growth of government a lot of
good things happen in the nineteen
sixties on civil rights and women's
rights not a lot of good things happen
in any other area of American life in
the 1960s the 1960s radicalized our
politics in tremendously damaging ways
for a variety of reasons the idea that
Trump is the is the be-all end-all
though is what the left is banked on and
this is why they can't stand why you got
Trump but this is why you got Trump it
is that you use the same slurs against
John McCain and Mitt Romney and George W
Bush you used against Trump and then you
got Trump congratulations this is how
you got there okay time for a quick
Federalist paper so we're all the way on
Federalist 44 Wow been doing this for a
while James Madison wrote this one and
in it he discusses why states should not
be able to for example print their own
currencies he said
just that this is going to lead to an
inflation race States racking up debt
and then being able to inflate their way
out of it as opposed to States racking
up debts and then having to tax their
way out of it this is basically correct
although I think there's a case to be
made that separate currencies among the
states might not be the world's worst
thing because then we would actually get
to see the fiscal effects of being
fiscally irresponsible like we see in
California as opposed to simply kicking
the can down the road and assuming that
the federal government is going to pick
up the slack because the US dollar is
going to support all of that spending
Madison also writes about the Necessary
and Proper Clause this is the the clause
of the Constitution that says that the
federal government has all powers
Necessary and Proper to the fulfillment
of its specific duties under the
Constitution of the United States the
case Madison makes is that the Necessary
and Proper Clause is enough of a
restriction on the federal government
that really we shouldn't worry about the
growth of the federal government and
Madison would have been right if all of
our constitutional officers had done
their job instead the Necessary and
Proper Clause was expanded to include
all sorts of means that were not in fact
Necessary and Proper here's what Madison
wrote he said a few parts of the
Constitution have been assailed with
more intemperance than this yet on a
fair investigation of it no part can
appear more completely invulnerable
without the substance of this power the
whole Constitution be a dead letter
those who is those who object to the
article therefore as a part of the
Constitution can only mean that the form
of the provision is improper in the
first instance the success of the
usurpation meaning if the government
takes power well depend on the executive
and judiciary departments which try to
expound and give effects of the
legislative acts and in the last resort
a remedy must be obtained from the
people who can buy the election more
faithful representatives and all the
acts of the usurpers in the end it's
gonna be up to the people to protect the
Constitution and this is where we fail
the American people have not protected
the Constitution we can blame our
politicians as much as we want the civic
education in our country sucks we have
not studied what the bounds of the
government ought to be or why they ought
to be there and thus we have delegated
all sorts of power to the feds and then
we whine about it after the feds use
that power against us that's a mistake
on our parts in the end it all comes
down to what the American people want
and I think it's the I think it's an HL
Mencken kind of aphorism that the
American people deserve a want they
deserve it good and hard then that's
sort of in the Madisonian view well it's
time for the American people to wake up
and maybe take some blame for the fact
that our politics is failing
finally Madison in Federalist
forty-four discusses the supremacy
clause he says that we have to have a
federal government that is supreme to
the state government otherwise the state
governments are going to supreme be
supreme over the federal government and
the whole thing won't work this
obviously is is fundamentally correct
okay
so we'll be back here tomorrow with all
the latest updates from the Brett
Kavanaugh hearings and everything else
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wha
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018